hello my name is emma watts playing the
past mighty ranger
walking onto the set of the
philosopher's stone was a dream come
true for daniel
emma and rupert hogwarts was basically
their playground
the film itself might deal with some
serious issues like a two-faced
professor looking for the demise of one
of his students
but for the most part the behind the
scenes was full of laughs
pranks and adorable on-set crushes
though there was one professor the
actors were petrified of
off camera ready to find out who
my name is gary i work for the rspc
if hogwarts was their playground the
rest of the children in the cast were
the golden trio's classmates
which as you can imagine led to a lot of
onset chaos
it was near impossible to get them all
focused at the same time
director chris columbus says they were
constantly laughing and
fooling around in between takes and
sometimes even during takes
look how adorable they all were it might
have taken some extra effort from the
adults on set
but on the bright side it led to
impeccable on-screen chemistry
the audition process for daniel emma and
rupert couldn't be any more different
for daniel it was just another day at
the theater with his parents
when producer david heyman who had
already had his eye on daniel for the
role
convinced them to just come in for an
audition sign up for the entire series
and uh it was all to be filmed in
america but
daniel's parents weren't really up for
relocating their 11 year old son
luckily they ended up filming in the uk
and it all worked out
emma attended a drama class for her
audition basically
my school got an invitation after she
was hand-selected from her classmates
she went on to audition eight more times
before she secured her spot
rupert's audition is probably the most
wild story we've heard so far
he heard about the open call auditions
and sent in a video of himself
dressed as his drama teacher while
performing a rap
then i made my script thing up and sent
it off
it may have landed him an in-person
audition but it didn't save him from
embarrassment
the golden trio had almost absolutely no
experience in film
which led to a lot of nervous actors on
the first day of filming
i was terrified not only were they
acting but they were learning the ins
and outs of memorizing lines and hitting
their marks
not to mention all the professional
lingo they made so many mistakes that
director chris
said he had to film with multiple
cameras each actor always had a camera
on them
this was so they could catch as much
footage as possible and piece it all
together
that's why the first film is a little
choppy they couldn't get through a full
scene without someone making a mistake
rupert don't smile and emma don't put
your head on forward chris deserves
all the awards for how much effort he
put into the film
he wasn't shy about how much he enjoyed
working with actors
but he went the extra level for the
amateur actors on set
a lot of the time he would be behind the
cameras acting the scene out alongside
daniel
emma and rupert so they could take
reference from him
look at him go i always you know laughed
and said we should put a camera on chris
we don't have access to all the bloopers
from the set
but we're willing to bet a lot of them
would include emma
while filming she had a habit of
mouthing everyone else's lines
and ruining entire takes we're sure they
appreciated how focused and eager she
was
but emma says the whole process
traumatized her i really wanted to do my
job well and i
and i kind of overdid it she of course
eventually worked through it
what would a movie set be without some
pranks for this franchise at least in
the early days
daniel was a prankster mastermind i'm an
angel
i'm an angel sure you were dan he was so
good he managed to get a hold of robbie
coltrane
also known as hagrid's phone and
reprogrammed it from
english to turkish genius besides that
he was constantly wandering set looking
for ways to prank people
performing magic tricks and overall
being cheeky
normally calling cut on set means
everyone breaks character
but a lot of the time alan rickman who
played snape would remain
in character between takes which also
meant dan and ripper were terrified of
him both
on and off camera i was constantly
having to remind myself that it was
certainly a film one time rupert drew a
funny caricature of alan rickman while
filming
rupert was absolutely terrified when he
realized allen had noticed a drawing
from over his shoulder
luckily this was one time alan decided
to break character i've made him
sign it and i have it in my possession
alan took it home and said it was
something that was very dear to him
our hearts it wouldn't be a set full of
preteens and teens without any crushes
developing
we didn't know it at the time but emma
watson revealed years later that she had
a major crush on tom felton
from the ages of 10 to 12. we love a bad
guy and he was a few years older and he
had a skateboard
and that just did it really but tom
would refer to her as a little sister
and she had her heart torn in two a lot
of people wondered why they wrote out
hermione's huge buck teeth in the script
well it was because emma watson couldn't
speak properly with them
teeth test keith's test
she did multiple camera tests with them
and even filmed one scene with them that
made it to the final cut but ultimately
it just didn't work out we all know the
irony of people telling harry
you have your mother's eyes when daniel
indeed did not
instead of the green eyes harry has in
the novel daniel had blue eyes
and it wasn't for lack of effort daniel
did try and wear contacts
but had a painful allergic reaction that
forced them to film without them
you know the scene at the end of the
philosopher's stone where harry is
saying goodbye to hagrid
his eyes were only puffy because he'd
been wearing them does that count as
method acting
the floating candles in the great hall
are iconic and they knew they had to get
them perfect
at first they were using real candles
hung with fishing line
but those candles started melting and
falling on the actors below
yikes that meant they only had one or
two takes to get the grand entrance
perfect
so the reaction you see from the first
years here
is the actual reaction from the kids it
was the first time they had seen that
set no acting required speaking of the
great hall
director chris says that those were the
most difficult scenes to film
that's because they had to control over
300 children in one space
even the child actors themselves don't
know how he managed it
i don't know how he does it he used
various techniques to get everything
perfect but then re-blocking for another
take would take forever
let the feast begin the great hall just
seems to be the place where everything
went awry
you know that delicious looking food
that always lines the tables in the
films
well for the first film that food was
very real
and needed to lasten through three days
of filming under the heat of the set
lights there was no way that food was
staying fresh
which meant the hall didn't smell very
pleasant
the philosopher's stone is like 99
focused on just
children which meant in order to film
the movie at the time they had to
petition for uk
labour law adjustments they managed to
get the kids on set for nine hours a day
but only about four to five of those
hours were filming
the rest were dedicated to school and
breaks it's tough
but we had brilliant kids and they did
really well owls played a huge role in
all of the films
and to take the movie realism to a whole
new level chris managed to use
real life trained owls it wasn't easy
but they managed to do it
the magical scene where that i will
swoop in to deliver the students post
was shot by filming owls individually
and then editing them all together later
on
owls are beautiful creatures but they
are difficult to train
we've never wanted a time turner more
we'd give
anything to just be a fly on the wall
and get to experience all of this
first hand looking back on the film that
started it all
it's amazing to see how far the actors
have come since their beginnings what
behind the scenes moments did you love
hearing about most